good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast
welcome to welcome yes welcome to the
morning toast
you are on another level in terms of
your pitch
yeah because um welcome to the morning
toast
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome
to the morning toast happy hump day
everyone doesn't quite feel like a hump
day because theo was super busy this
morning and wasn't able to make it to
the studio so if you're watching live on
youtube
i genuinely apologize not only for
theo's absence but b for a couple audio
issues we've had this week we're still
working it out
hopefully it is fixed today do let us
know if it isn't fixed i know you will
anyway
yeah um hi i missed you it's a beautiful
day
in new york city so i'm so glad he's out
there you know
as long as he's out there somewhere
where he can go um
i feel like we should acknowledge you
know this specific time of year it's
such a special time of year
where it's definitely between summer and
winter i know that they consider that
fall
but it just happens so fast and fall is
either like really cold or like you're
still getting chub rubbed from the
summer
and this week has just been an absolute
delight it's just
sublime really has been today's like
gonna be the warmer
of the days of the books and so i'm
burying my legs once again i know you
guys missed them
so that's a crazy thing to do at the
height of fall yes
it's also a crazy thing to do to wear
this romper on this show because it's
really short
and i was hoping for a theo covered
thigh today
but i didn't get that so i'm here out
here in all my bravery saying hello to
my little thighs
theo is definitely like um an emotional
support but he's also a physical support
covers thighs legs arm he does but i'm
just gonna
brave it i'm gonna own my choice no
you're gonna brave it
bravely yeah and extremely very boy um
so today's a fabulous episode because
it's wednesday which means you're
automatically just going to get an
amazing episode because we do dear
toasters on wednesday
which is our advice segment so we'll do
that at the end of the show but
normally we would not have any tv show
am i normally we wouldn't have any tv to
recap on wednesdays
but jackie and i both spent the greater
part of yesterday
the whole day the whole day catching up
on selling sunset which is something we
have been wanting to do
something we said we were gonna do and i
just decided to take the plunge i
actually tried to start watching the
other day but
my netflix was like not working and it
wouldn't play for me so i was like oh
maybe this isn't my journey
but i gave it another shot yesterday and
it played and we have
so many thoughts claudia and i were
watching like all day at the same time
just like texting each other our
thoughts honestly we should publish our
text messages they're so
funny like some of them are a little
mean are not publishable
um to be honest i feel like you and i
are not in the majority and i used to
think that i had the most like universal
thoughts on reality tv but over the last
few seasons of like housewives and just
different things we've rekept i have
found that like we do not have the
popular opinion
and i certainly do not have the popular
opinion on selling sunset so if you're
like a christelle stan
you might want to turn this off you
we're up to season two
episode five so if something big
happened in season three we don't know
about it yet
we've really avoided spoilers um
but as to where we are now like i
absolutely stand
right or die like we'll never go again
never waver christine quinn and i know
that's unpopular is it i don't care i
don't want to hear it like
usually i know i mean i i read what
everyone else has to say i see that
they're valid but i
but i have some sort of feeling in my
heart and i just can't explain it i
understand
this is not that no i can explain it 100
i
don't know how anyone could see anything
else this woman is
everything of the sort um
i have some i like want to save all of
my thoughts we will get to it
we'll get to it after the past five but
i have so many thoughts but that's
really where our thoughts are going to
take us which is that christine quinn
like deserves
everything she deserves and you know
what it appears as if she might be
getting everything
that she has everything because i went
stalking her instagram and it's just
full of everything it's full of
actually premium content so in our tv
recap segment we will be recapping what
we have gotten up to and i feel as if by
tomorrow at the same rate we will
probably be done with selling sunsets
if you're looking for the full recap
that'll be tomorrow but first
impressions
first impressions i actually think i
have sort of a busy day today but maybe
i could squeeze the rest of it in
but we'll figure it out we'll be done by
the end of the week
yeah i love now being like included in
people's conversations because i've seen
so much content especially on tick tock
with just like different selling sunset
jokes like davina's 75 million dollar
thing and like i literally had no idea
what they were talking about so now i
just love being included
yeah i like being included also the way
that the show is filmed is just like
excellent quality the conversations i
think even season one like either
they're really good at their makeup or
they got glam for every
uh filming and it's just it's a pleasure
to watch so
we'll be recapping that and of course
delivering the past five so i guess
without theo here there's really like no
time like the president to just get into
it because
you know we could always wax poetic
about him but when he's not here to
listen to the accolades
what's the point what's the point if if
theo gets a compliment in the woods and
no one's there to hear it
did it ever really happen yes i agree
but without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
yep and i have nothing to say i'm
feeling pretty good my rdh has passed
that's good but you want to keep an eye
on it because you just never know when
it could flare up again
100 and it's all good thank you for all
the well wishes
in my journey to the cure for rdh it's
really sweet
okay first story big story of the day
lauren conrad went on whitney port's
podcast and they're just
going down memory lane and she's
revealing why she distanced herself from
the hills
cast oh my god i had no idea i saw like
a few headlines that were so clickbaity
that i didn't even
read the lauren conrad story but i love
that she went on whitney port's podcast
i feel like
those are the two queens in my opinion
and like i'm glad that they see each
other
yeah while they met on the hit mtv
series as interns at teen vogue nearly
15 years ago
conrad has not remained close with her
former castmates since she left the show
in 2009
and did not appear in the series revival
and while they couldn't come physically
together because of the pandemic they
did finally catch up virtually for
whitney's podcast
with wit spoiler alert they were quite
honest with each other
okay as port told conrad quote i would
say the question that i get asked the
most
most of the time is are you still
friends with lauren that's what people
really want to know
that's how people really got to know us
was together in teen vogue closet and
people always want to know the behind
the scenes and like if there was any
drama
her answer proved no matter their
distance that port will always have
lauren's back
my answer to them is always you know
it's friends that you went to college
with good friends that you had really
special experiences with
that you always have love for but that
you don't always keep in touch with
right
conrad agreed quote i think like what
you said is perfectly describing it i
have so much love in my heart for you
and like we shared this really weird
unique thing and i think it is
it's like old college friends you know
i'll always remember you like that and
i'll never have that with anybody else
yeah i feel like lauren has kind of been
really ambiguous
like and super distant from the hills
girls in the hills franchise
and i do think that i actually believe
that this is the case for her and
whitney like i don't think that they're
best friends like calling each other
every day but they don't have bad things
to say about each other and it's just
you do you grow apart like you forget
like these kids were like 21 years old
but i don't think that's the case with
lauren and all of the cast memes and i
definitely think there are a lot of
people that she
intentionally is not keeping in touch
she has bad blood with but the way that
lauren and
whitney describe their friendship now or
their relationship now like i feel that
way about certain people too it's like
i never talk to you i never see you but
when i do it's such a pleasure and like
we can go down memory lane
yeah and have a good time i feel like
the way the
relationship they're describing is like
a very common adult relationship when
it's like
you're phasing out of college into the
real world and as years go by and time
passes on
you realize you like these people
technically like you haven't seen them
in forever like they're not really like
your friends but you'll always
love them and appreciate the time you
spent together yes and i feel like
that's a very mature
thing to do a very mature thing to do
speaking of lauren conrad
on that episode of selling sunset where
the wag co-owner
um wanted to get a house for herself and
she sent like
a memorable team and they said that she
looked like lauren conrad okay she looks
like hillary does
that's what i thought too when the woman
showed up i'm like is this a surprise
hillary duff is a
co-founder of wag i thought the same
thing and then they were like you look
so much like i'm like okay finally
they're going to address it
yeah lauren conrad the girl was like
yeah i get that all the time i'm like
you do you literally look nothing like
her sometimes they feel like
the way people look on tv like even
though they're not doing anything
different just like the way they look on
tv is just not what they look like if
you were to meet them in real life i
also think like
as a society you know as a society we
are progressing past
certain things like it's really not
appropriate to ask people you know when
they're getting pregnant like there are
things we're evolving past
and i think we need as a society to
evolve past telling people who they look
like
because it never comes off flattering
unless you're literally telling me like
you look like giselle claudia like
oh my god is that heidi klum i'm
insulted i don't care like
i have a certain image of myself in my
head and it might not be what the world
sees but it's what i see
and when somebody disrupts what i see
with like oh you look like this or
showing me a picture like of his
instagram i get it all the time in my
dm's like yeah of a random girl but i
thought this was you and like
i take it as an insult i do because
that's not what i think i look like i
think as a society
we have to evolve past that we no longer
can tell people who they look like
i think you might be alone in that i
don't i don't think so i understand no i
mean
on on this between the two of us
i think people do agree with you um i
think that
yes sometimes it can be so insulting
like i get
i get really some like tragic stuff and
it's not that the person that they're
comparing to you to
is like ugly it's just like you have a
certain image of yourself that you
protect
in your mind yes but then other times i
look at other people and i'm actually
really good
at um realizing who people remind me of
like
not even who they it might be who they
look like but it's also just their
mannerisms
and that was something i was going to
say about selling sunset they all look
like different remind me of other people
like mixtures of other people
and if i reminded someone so closely of
someone else in the way that i see
comparisons
i would want to know like so then i
could look at them be like oh i guess
that's what i'm like okay but for the
most part
people compare you to other people based
on physical looks
not always on on mannerisms maybe one
out of ten times but it's mostly on
looks
yeah i guess maybe but also
sometimes they'll send me people who are
like blonde who i don't think look like
me but like there's something about
their smile that like
reminds me of them and i just find it
interesting and i don't take them all
and and
judge myself based on what well i don't
find them every comparison i get in the
dm and if you're listening to this
maybe just don't ever tell me who you
think i look like i think that's a good
a good rule like claudia doesn't enjoy
it no but i i don't want to say that i
do because then i'll get so many i just
got one the other day and like i really
didn't [ __ ] ballerina yeah i saw it
too
did you see the comparison did you see
that i look like her no she just had red
hair and pale skin
right like you could be renesme you know
like you could be anyone right i don't
i don't [ __ ] with that just because i'm
like i don't want to don't tell me i
look like another redhead but like if i
really have like similar
well like with madeleine patch like you
guys actually look physically alike not
just beyond
the red hair yeah but it's like when
sarah foster
watches selling sunset does she see her
face on christine quinn because that's
all i see
what christine quinn is sarah foster's
face
christine quinn is christina aguilera
and erica james
100 to me christine quinn is sarah
foster and jeffrey starr
with a sprinkle of erika jane oh my god
i totally do not see sarah foster
whatsoever in christine
oh i see has anyone else ever made that
comparison i don't think so i mean
now let's go through our comparisons
because maya is literally the israeli
sutton foster with a little bit of
giselle and gwyneth paltrow brunette
gwyneth paltrow
but sutton foster is like 80 she's 80
satan foster to me 21 gwyneth powell
also she's 100
my friend daniella orleans like if
anyone knows her it's [ __ ] crazy like
she's also dutch so she speaks with an
accent and like they carry themselves
the same way and they're so tall
it freaks me out they're so similar um
heather is christina
and um davina is like pam from the
office like she's like
so basic she's like i don't have anyone
for her she's the only one who doesn't
really remind him of someone else's
office
um kimmy schmidt oh i guess but when she
had brown hair
ellie kemper in the office she had brown
hair okay that's who davina is okay i
feel that and
christelle you said she's andy dorfman
oh my god
one uh unequivocally andy dorfman i
think she's andy dorfman plus jojo
fletcher
and all of them on the show are a
mixture of two people yeah also amanza i
haven't figured out who she is
it's bothering me so much i'm gonna get
to it it took me a whole season
to figure out who season one people
looked like i'm gonna figure out who
amanda
reminds me of and it's gonna rock your
world and i need like to me
these comparisons are on point christine
quinn is sarah foster like even the way
she just like
looks at you not like oh my god
every her face like if you just like
took her face off
and put it next to sarah foster's
they're twins
to me like i think christy and quinn
like might be a
like a child of david foster oh my god
jackie there's nothing that's [ __ ]
way
i will die on this hill they like if you
don't see it
you're not looking right nothing like no
oh my god claudia
how can you say that nothing how can you
say that are you back to this lauren
conrad story oh
back to lauren conrad she doesn't look
like the girl from selling sunsets oh
yeah that's what it was
but i'm happy that her and whitney are
still friends i feel like of all the
friendships like that was the most
mature you know whitney was like so
she was like kind of better than
everyone else so above it all
yeah she was like lauren's work friend
but she was really like this
genius like i feel like everyone really
respected her yeah for sure
and it's it's still really surprising
that she went on like the reboot
i think she's above it but she stays
above it on the reboot so like barely on
it
yeah but like she just like did her
crest white strips integration
yeah she has her really cute family and
she does
she doesn't get down in the mud and so
if she can do that good for her a lot of
people can't can't play that role
because then
they'll get axed i honestly i'm just
shocked that lauren um conrad like even
publicly associated with someone from
the hills i feel like she's just like
literally since it's been over has acted
like it never happened and she's had so
much success so she doesn't like need to
go back and like do
reboots and podcasts about the hills i
just can't believe like she actually
publicly put her name somewhere like
with someone from the hills yeah i just
feel like
she couldn't have been more distant from
it yeah but i appreciate it
you know me too okay next story haters
be damned ellen sees the highest
premiere ratings since 2016.
of course i mean who wouldn't want to
tune in to this [ __ ] show um
yeah she's more interesting than ever i
know
but you know some people who don't want
to watch her anymore like might make
that known but the show posted an
overnight nielsen household rating of
1.9
steady with the overall ratings for the
fall 2019 premiere but it ranked number
one in a lucrative ad demo
adults aged 25 to 54 with a 0.9 rating
and an increase from last year's 0.8
okay
i have to be honest like i legit don't
understand ratings
for the life of no me neither anytime i
go and like seek out ratings like i'm
curious like
are people watching more bravo or more e
like i just try and like find the
information
like is this show doing i always want to
know what the ratings of something are
and i feel like unless there's like an
article telling me i can't make sense of
it
right also um not only is it nonsensical
it's also nearly impossible to find the
data when it's like should be public
it is public information but it's right
nearly impossible so when nielsen has a
rating of 1.9
million how does that mean 1.9 million
people watch it because
could you just tell me how much people
watch it i think so and if it was like
0.9 that would be 900 000. and then it
was like .09 it would be like 90
000. yeah so i just
i just want to know how many people
watch things there needs to be like a
website or an instagram account yes
please
puts this together because i think that
i want to know no i definitely want to
know and especially it's just so
interesting with like
cable really kind of being on the
decline in so many digital shows like
having
such strong numbers like are there
digital shows that actually do better
than tv shows you know like that's what
i want to know
and digital numbers are so clear and so
public and you can just see
what anyone's watching on youtube like
the numbers are just right there and i
feel like
almost intentionally cable data numbers
are so like misleading and confusing
yeah i feel that as well so mr nielsen
podcast numbers are so private
what's the word opaque yeah that's
really true it kind of reminds me of
tumblr
where like literally nobody knew how
many followers you had so like you could
have the biggest tumblr in the world and
like literally nobody would
would know what's the point um and
podcasts are the same way it's like
yes so you could see like if someone's
on the charts like they obviously have a
lot of numbers but like
people are on the charts who literally
have five thousand listings and have
five million listings it's all about
it's like it's a formula kelty kelty was
telling us about it but
it's safe to say like we know what the
biggest podcasts in the world are as
opposed to tumblr right you don't know
of course but i just feel like every
influencer has a podcast and they make
it seem like it's the biggest podcast in
the world and
i would do i mean i do do the same
because like that's what
building a brand and building a business
online is but i would love to see some
numbers like how many people actually
listen to all these podcasts like i know
how many people listen to mine
and i know how many people listen to all
the tnn shows but i
it like honestly it kills me i'm so
curious no it's it's so
curiosity-inducing
right like there are actually like five
people who have podcasts like
i just want to know that these five you
know i'm not going to say who they are
obviously but like
they're trying like our competitors no
no no no no like just random people that
i follow on the internet
um who just like have podcasts and like
make it seem like it's like
oh now i know you're talking so like
i don't even want to know all the
podcasts in the world numbers like i
just want to know like these five people
like who i just like
wanna know i wish like so badly i could
just
say start guessing oh no no no no you
can't you can't but you know who it is
yeah
i know one okay next up teddy mellencam
confirms real housewives of beverly
hills exit
okay what the title should be telling
ellie camp
confirms real housewives of beverly
hills exit in bizarrely
passive aggressive strange video
bizarrely passive aggressive
sad video like at first i was like
cringe and then i was like my heart
softened well so
i actually felt a bunch of different
ways about the video the first was
obviously like it was just like really
strong like it was just kind of bizarre
um but two i actually had a lot of
respect for her for actually admitting
she was
let go slash not renewed because i feel
like a lot of housewives in their time
have been
not renewed and they always go on social
media being like this journey
so i had respect for that but i was
blinded by the
don't want to bore you
i i appreciate and respect her attempt
at like
being sassy yeah i just think it did it
felt a little short
yeah no it was like i feel like that
video sums up her journey on the show
right like came coming off really strong
right out of the gate and then she talks
about how like
she loved her experience and she did the
coolest things and she's gonna really
miss the cast and crew and and then i
was like oh now i feel sad
yeah cause to be honest like no matter
how
teddy mellencamp without housewives like
has a fabulous life like she's john
mellencamp's daughter she has a
wonderful marriage and a wonderful
wonderful family they have a ton of
money she's really successful he's
really successful
so it's it's not that her life you know
is gonna severely deteriorate without
the show
but the show no matter how rich and
famous you are or how many celebrities
you're connected to
it is an amazing experience like these
trips that they take on beverly hills
like
are beyond trips that most of the women
take like it really is like a special
experience and a really good opportunity
so
towards the end of the video i did feel
like she's gonna she wasn't ready to go
and she's like gonna be missing out on
you know all the fun and all the stuff
um coming up i just can't recall it
there's i don't really feel like
there's another housewife departure i
can compare this to where it was like
leaked
basically confirmed before the housewife
or bravo got to even
mention anything yeah i don't know
someone in production like had it out
for teddy because the page six and daily
mail articles were so oddly specific and
really mean
yeah and now that i think about it i
actually i don't really think it's
fair not that it's saying she didn't
like that she didn't deserve
to be fired but i don't think it's fair
to fire someone
after a season where they're pregnant
because she
she continues to do so much you know
like i think i
think back to like when monique was
pregnant um on potomac and like
she kind of she played an interesting
role because instead of getting involved
in the drama she really became the voice
of reason so like
she had cemented her place place in that
way
but i don't know there was only so much
teddy could have done on like one she
obviously can't drink so she can't just
like
you know see what happens like drink and
see what happens which i think some
housewives do just to start drama
two like you can't let your blood
pressure your stress levels spike that
much so she really had to stay
neutral and boring that's actually a
really really like
interesting observation my only rebuttal
is that
i know people said like this daily mail
article said that she was fired for
being boring
and i in the past maybe have found some
of her content boring but i didn't think
at all actually this season she was
boring
i think she was mean and she's not
really friends with anyone but kyle and
neither of those things have to do with
her being pregnant
so i feel like she was fired more so for
those reasons like she's really not a
part of the group like
yeah no i'm not saying she like that
she shouldn't be fired because she was
pregnant i'm just saying like it sets a
bad tone
you automatically are gonna have a low
like a
not a low season but like a quieter
calmer
season it's not going to be a big season
for you if you're pregnant because you
have a lot going on and there's a
million different reasons why
you shouldn't be participating in
certain things um
so she didn't really get a chance to
bounce back but maybe it was like
last season this season was her you know
right you never did this might have been
her redemption season you never know
what kind of conversations go on no but
that's interesting it does set like a
weird tone and like
not a good one yeah anyways she'll be
missed
you know i wonder who will replace her
i mean i feel like now they're they're
down to with sutton and teddy i mean
with denise and teddy i feel like sutton
will be a full-time housewife and then
they're only down one
i don't really think they need anyone
else i hope garcelle
stays even though she's now so busy
hosting the real
but i actually think she will stay me
too and then they're only down one and i
think that
that's fine yeah i would like to see
them bring someone else in maybe even
like
a former housewife someone who doesn't
need like a full re-introduction
to the group honestly someone like kind
of like kathy hilton who like we kind of
know
through so much about her like from kyle
and kim and
obviously her famous kids so i actually
think it might be a good season for
kathy elton she was
actually weirdly in my dream last night
kathy hilton oh wow
then like before bed was like kathy
hilton's joining housewives oh my god
and i'm like
you know who kathy hilton is that's like
yeah
um okay well next story rolling stone
has released their 500 best albums of
all time list
this is a list that they've had and now
they've re-released it to include
newer albums oh that's so interesting um
some albums that have now made
the list that weren't on it before
include
taylor swift's red oh my god how was
that not on it before and adele's 21
because it came out before that album
came out
oh when did this original list come out
i think it's something that they've
always
had it debuted in 2003 so they do have
to
update it sometimes and they've just
updated so i'm going to go through the
top albums a lot of them are not new
albums okay
um but i also just want to say like put
it out there i
really really appreciate how much
rolling stone respects taylor swift like
how much they respect red yeah but they
are always putting her on these lists
and
i think a lot of like music
like snobs would be like taylor swift
but rolling stone really leans into it
and they appreciate like the true talent
and the artistry and the songwriting and
the music making
and i just wanted to put it out there
that as a swifty i really appreciate
billingstone like being cool
yeah and i think this list is
interesting if you're ever looking to
get into a good album like
i've you know i'm actually now having
deja vu from the old studio where we
spoke about this
yeah i think it's an interesting lace so
the number one greatest album of all
time according to a rolling stone
is marvin gaye what's going on okay
number two the beach boys pet sounds
boring number three joni mitchell blue
number four stevie wonder songs in the
key of life i couldn't agree more
actually we actually went to the songs
in the key of life tour at madison
square garden like when we were in high
school
and was phenomenal it was phenomenal
number five the beatles abbey road
sure number six nirvana never mind with
the little baby and the dollar
on the cover number seven fleetwood mac
rumors
sunder only heaven
when it was raining number eight
prince and the revolution purple rain
purple rain that was so
good thank you oh my god i'm like shook
thank you i'm flustered
number nine bob dylan blood on the
tracks okay
number 10 lauren hill the miseducation
of lauryn hill
you know speaking of lauryn hill i need
to watch sister act like i've just been
i've been having an itch for it recently
and i think like this weekend is my time
it's a content upper first it is such a
and honestly
the first is just as good as the second
yeah and there's very few like sequels
like that
number 11 the beatles revolver 12
michael jackson thriller
13 aretha franklin i never loved a man
the way i love you
14 the rolling stones exile on main
street
15 public enemy it takes a nation of
millions to hold us back
i've literally never heard of that
number 16 the clash
london calling okay like tell me when
like a contemporary album number 17
kanye west my beautiful dark twisted
fantasy wow
that's an honor that is an honor it's a
great album all right go down the list
in order now just have contemporary
albums
okay but if they don't organize that way
but i'll just try and like skip over
um number 19 kendrick lamar to pimp a
butterfly
i agree 20 radiohead kid a
21 bruce springsteen born to run not
contemporary but something you've heard
of yeah
22 notorious big ready to die
um next one that you might have heard of
or that you enjoyed oh 20 32 beyonce
lemonade
oh i agree 33 amy winehouse back to
black
i definitely agree this must be a really
hard list to put together this is a hard
time
i haven't even listened to all the
albums in the world but like out of my
favorite albums how would i
i couldn't even imagine i feel like when
an album comes out
rolling stone has like a database and
they give it like a score based on
different categories and then
when they put this together it's just
like who has the highest score yeah
that's a good point that's just how i
assume it i don't know how people could
do this any other way
50 jay-z the blueprint so where's red
i mean it's 99 okay that's not bad
no that's pretty good okay good for her
yeah i just
think it is interesting and 21 by adele
was added to the list as well
yes and which was 25. what what was on
21 that's not what
under the bridge that's in the deep
rolling
[Music]
you've had my heart and soul
in your hands and you played it
wow okay
we'll just cut that out okay
fifth and final story leading us into
our tv recap of selling sunsets it's
been like just
literally spilling out of me but this is
a story in its own right that will
naturally segue into selling sunset
recap
christina and stead and husband and
you're like who are these people
oh no no no el
split after less than two years of
marriage i mean tariq and christina just
time after time have proved to be like
the messiest celebrities alive
i mean at first it was the whole saga in
the mountains with the gun
and that was really scary and that's
really where like it wasn't funny
anymore you know
then they got divorced then they both um
fell into new relationships she moved on
really quickly and not only
founded her boyfriend really quickly but
got married really quickly yes now
they're getting divorced
heather is still with tariq it's just
it's honestly too much
for me as a viewer and i actually used
to really like their show when they were
married i mean i never thought they had
a good marriage and you could tell that
they totally hated each other
but it was a good tv show because they
used to flip houses like for really
cheap and they had like literally the
shittiest style it was like interesting
to watch
um but this is just like an i don't know
they have three kids together and i just
i don't know it's it's really not a good
situation
yeah they said aunt and i have made a
difficult decision to separate and
ant aunt is it it's on to snitches
okay on sneakers and i have made a
difficult decision to separate we are
grateful for each other
and as always our children will remain
our priority we appreciate
your support i'm getting choked up and
asked for privacy for us and our family
as we navigate the future
this is like a real like
it's so crazy how much heather looks
like
christina and how much and to sneeze yes
it looks like tarek okay so
and also ari dyke yes yes yes yes
um let's dive into to selling sunset
just with this heather situation so
i didn't know who heather was i didn't
know that she ended up being tark's
girlfriend in the first season like she
looked like someone's so familiar
and then in the second season when they
showed that tmz article that she was
dating tariq al-musa like my jaw hit the
floor like
so many pieces were just like
immediately put together in my brain
and i was like oh my god this is epic
yeah uh claud i was a few episodes ahead
of claudia and i called her and i'm like
you need to make it to season two
episode one first ten minutes first ten
minutes
call me yeah and i'm so glad that it
didn't disappoint because i was worried
i wasn't going to hype it up too much
for you
i'm honestly going to go through our
text messages and i just want to see
what we spoke about
okay but um while we're on the subject
of heather like
i can't okay um so the first thing i
texted you was christelle was andy
dorfman because i
felt so strongly about that obviously
the christelle hartley justin hartley of
it all was like a huge pull for her now
we know he like dumped her via text
message
yeah i don't know in the third season if
it was pre-divorced or post-divorce i'm
hoping it was post-divorce
because i think it was post-divorce and
i think that we know that he dumped her
via text message because the timeline's
starting
adding up i think she says that on
season three got it got it got it that's
what i'm thinking but i don't know and i
don't want to know and if i'm wrong
we'll correct it tomorrow or the next
day
um so in terms of like the big i would
say
divide within the show and just the fans
is like crochetl versus christine
chris yes because there are two types of
people in this world
i couldn't agree more and i feel like in
the beginning
christelle was like weenie and like
everyone
in the audience like was not really into
her and i think by the second season a
lot of feel that people feel like she
got her voice back and like her power
back
and i actually couldn't agree with that
less i know that some may seem crazy
christine is like a little bit of a bull
bond like very direct
um kind of mean a little bit [ __ ] but
i love someone who can own their
bitchiness and
christine is really not afraid to
apologize which i thought she actually
might be
yeah like she's very direct and very can
be
mean but the apology that she gave
krishell season two episode one at the
44 million dollar house was so genuine
and like she really just [ __ ] fell on
her sword yep
and that's not what i i expected from
her i thought she was just going to try
and like
patch it up and i feel like the fact
that christelle couldn't see that that
was genuine or like she was just like
holding on to this grudge because she
felt like she had to
yeah where it's like you know i actually
thought in season one the two of them
had a really nice scene when they were
at the bar
and they got dreams talking about high
school talking about high school they
were both like had tears in their eyes
and they
and they hugged and i and i thought that
that was like the bedrock for actually
a good friendship even if they're not
going to be the best of friends like
just some mutual respect so when like
things went so sideways
and christelle was like christy never
liked me and never wanted to be my
friend i'm like
that's not really true i agree 100 and
while christine was
definitely wrong at the pool party she
totally blew it out of proportion
i could see her just like really wanting
to defend her friend defend her friend
mary
and then also feeling like blindsided
when she's out here defending her friend
mary and mary gets up and hugs chriselle
like it makes now christine look like an
[ __ ] yeah and she also said
like i was drinking i was intense she
tried to call crochelle that night and
apologize like
okay so she didn't handle herself so
perfectly in the moment but like she
tried to make it right and christelle
just like refuses just like loves to be
the victim
yes a hundred percent and so in terms of
krishel um i'm not surprised like so
many of the fans love her because i feel
like she's super sweet and she's super
cute
no actually that's not at all what i was
gonna say i'm not surprised that so many
people like her she's just
a very specific type of girl and i feel
like if i was in college and like she
was in my sorority like i would stay so
far away from her
she gives me just like this weak vibe
like she has she's
weak like and and honestly in terms of
her job i feel like she's so
unprofessional almost
all the time like she's like giddy and
like jumpy and like
be professional like you're in a room
with business people and she's just like
jumping around and like
i don't know everything about her gives
me like an immature vibe when it comes
to her work and when it comes to her
friendships as well
very interesting i don't know i feel
like christelle like when she walked in
the first day with like her dog treats
and her big smile like i feel like she's
a really nice sweet
person um she definitely like
plays the victim because i think that's
where she feels comfortable but
aside from that like i think she's she's
probably a really nice girl and maybe
in season two and a half and three like
she does become stronger
well to be honest in the first season i
actually agreed
with what christine and davina were
saying because she was acting
one way in front of the girls but like
in her commentary she was like really
[ __ ] and i'm like also
and honestly it was like funny and i
liked it but like she was in a lot of
ways two-faced like she was like this
innocent little kitty cat in the office
and then she would say like crazy like
things in her commentary
it's not even like she's saying crazy
things what i've noticed about her is
that whenever there's a group
like there's a group she's always the
one to like bring
up right like let's talk about someone
mary and romain
yeah mary and romain when she was in uh
when she like had a glass of wine with
mary in the office afterwards like she
brought up
christine like she's always like she
says she's asking questions but she's
always asking like
leading goading questions or wanting the
other person to say something bad
and that's exactly what she did with
davina when you look back on it it's
like she was asking these leading
questions are they getting a prenup
because she wants like someone else
that's what was saying she was like yeah
you're asking questions but you're
asking them from like a negative place
yeah no you're asking them with judgment
yeah also um krishell completely lost me
100
when she ruined maya's baby announcement
like the fact that maya didn't get mad
at her
maya's not like involved in the drama i
actually love maya but she's really
stays above the fray
um the fact that she didn't get more mad
at rochelle like i actually wanted to
like
shake christelle in that scene like so
crazy
unacceptable especially that's what i
mean she's just that type of girl and i
literally would never be friends with
someone like that
yeah because to be the person when you
barely know this person to me the person
in the room with the pregnancy tax
test is like such an honor and i felt
like huge when i first saw that scene i
was like wow krishelle is just like this
rock and she's a supportive friend and
she's going to be there for you she's
going to cheer you on and like
or you know she might be there for a hug
if it doesn't go the way that you want
it to
and i was happy she was there for mom
yeah and i was like she's a real like
she's just probably a very good friend
and like
a very supportive person and the fact
that like she wouldn't even think
twice before she like she knew my head
told her on a few different occasions
like
she's very cautious and the fact that it
just slipped out was like
so crazy unacceptable in my opinion she
lost me for good
um and then in terms of davina i feel
like
after the third season like now in real
time davina's kind of become like this
huge villain
at the present moment i don't hate her
that much honestly when her and
christelle were like
really butting heads in the office
talking about burning man and then
divina was like well how much was your
dress like that was everything i'm not
sure what
like christelle was trying to say like
about burning man it did come off like
really condescending like really you
went to a festival and we did charity
like it was obnoxious it's so obnoxious
because again i thought christelle in
that moment was being like
so open and and she was sharing her
story with at the
when they were doing the charity work
and everyone sort of like
it really brought everyone together and
it was a really beautiful moment and
then to go and use that moment to like
sort of shame davina into not like
because she wasn't there it's like
that's not what charity is blind-hearted
yeah like that is the worst kind like
to use a good deed that right you have
done against someone else like
and then to go and say like how much was
your ticket that could have how much
let's with these houses that we're
selling yeah like but by the way
that is the two-facedness i feel like
christine and davina were referring to
and i saw it i did even before they
reckon like before they
pointed it out like just i saw i thought
she was really two different people
on the couch in the commentary than she
was with the other girls and i think
after the first season she
immediately stopped doing that because
that was what really like they were
talking about
um and i don't feel like she does that
anymore but i do see why davina and
christine like didn't like her in the
beginning
if i was in that office i 100 would not
have liked to rachelle one because she's
just not my type of girl i find her like
i can't use another word she's just like
weak like in every sense of the word
and she is two-faced yeah and i know we
are alone in this because people
hate davina they don't like christine
but they like she has a lot to offer
besides like the actual story line i am
just so obsessed with everything about
her and like her personality
her commentary and the fact that like so
there's also two types of people in this
world
everyone goes on season one of their
reality show and
you know is who they are and then talks
a big game in the interviews
yeah but then you have to answer for
those things if there's a reunion or
season two
or on social media and then most people
stop
doing that because they don't want to
have to answer for those things
krischell is one of those people who
might have these her thoughts haven't
changed but she's
not going to share them to share them
and to put herself in some sort of
villainous position
whereas christine just is who she is and
is going to say what she thinks
now i want to talk about mary and
romaine because not only
do i not understand their relationship
whatsoever i don't think they understand
their relationship they have
such a hard time communicating and their
scenes are so boring and i literally
scroll
like fast forward through them all the
time and when they got engaged i'm like
oh that's actually kind of sweet and
then she comes into the office and it's
moist tonight and
i'm really worried i was defeating it
but you wouldn't know why
because up until that moment mary talked
a big game about how successful she was
and like all this stuff and this life
and this life in this life
and he is like this world-renowned
pastry chef and i just feel like there's
absolutely nothing wrong with the moist
night ring whatsoever but like
putting up the front at first was what
was really deceptive
right and then when she was like showing
every like after
the office when she told him his
poisoning she was like going to
different places and showing her ring
it's like do you always have to say
that it's moist tonight just shut up
honestly it looked real like just let
everything i know that was
so stunning just let everyone think it
yeah i just don't like mary at all
honestly
romaine reminds me a lot of roman from
real housewives of
miami um they look alike and both of
their names are roman romain and like
they're both in dysfunctional
relationships
yeah um i just i don't like mary at all
and i don't get why she's the favorite
um she actually is a really good real
estate agent um obviously her
relationship with jason has something to
do with it i'm also curious and also
like the relationship with jason is
is weird is weird and it's not
appropriate like
given that she's engaged to someone else
also it's like a weird workplace
relationship but it seems like that's
just the norm you know
heather keeps saying she's like inviting
herself to live with jason like was that
was that brett oh can't tell them apart
they look like bowling balls
um but who is
i feel like jason is the boss of brett
like they're not partners that was the
vibe that i was getting
i feel like one of them i feel like
jason's in charge of
the agents and brett like must do
something else and
yes you know because they're always
taking their [ __ ] to jason
yeah right right and they like walk past
bread like he's not sitting right now
but like maybe
brad is like head of development or
something like where he's not
interfacing with the agents all the time
yeah
i mean the real estate part of it was
actually really interesting and you and
i were discussing on text about how like
i literally
we always talk about how living in l.a
would be fabulous but i'm like
shocked at these five million dollar
houses they're like not that big and not
that like they're nice on the inside
but they're tiny they don't have yards
risk your life
driving up a hill to get there no i'm
really not into la real estate is what
i've learned
there has been two houses that i've
absolutely adored they were both mary's
listings
one the one she sold to that girl emily
who was like the most stunning person
ever she was so stunning and that house
and that's where she offered oh and then
the other house the dohini house is
where the wedding is going to be with
the grass on the front yeah the but
that's not the emily house
oh right the emily house is where the
reading no yeah yeah yeah okay wait
first of all about mary
just one second again she's so
successful so successful she's the best
agent she gets all the listings
why can't she find a wedding venue it's
not like she lives remotely like in
idaho she lives in l.a with hotels and
venues christine found a place she went
to eric buterbauer's
uh floral shop for her engagement party
why couldn't
mary find a venue but so that's what i'm
saying about it
there's a who has their family member
who has a wedding date without a venue
that's not
who people book flights without an
invitation or anything yeah that is so
crazy but to like be like my wedding's
in six weeks but there's no wedding you
just like
put a date on a calendar and yeah i'm
going to get married on this day that's
what i'm like about
60 people are going to come her life is
a little bit of a front because i don't
know
it's one thing okay you can't find a
band but like they're all booked
how do you have a wedding you don't
really have a wedding day without a
wedding venue no you you don't at all
and you're just like begging people for
favors like no it's
so strange i really thought that they
were going to wind up just getting
married at jason's and i'm like this is
so weird
okay but back to um those two houses i
agree the johiny house is sickening
the emily house is sickening those were
my two favorites i'm learning
some stuff about like my taste in real
estate well so and i also think that if
we lived in la i would 100 live in the
valley
i don't like the hills the hollywood
hills i think the houses are too close
to each other
and also we went to a party once in the
hollywood hills i think that's the only
time i've ever been there and by the
time we got there i was going to throw
up like i'm
actually just like i can't live on a
really high floor in new york city
i don't think i could live up in the
hills so not only were we literally
about to
vomit on the way there first it was so
windy we had like a drink at dinner it
was just like not conducive
once we got there it was so packed that
literally in the living room had these
houses are built like on stilts on hills
the floor was shaking like yeah there
were too many people in this
it was a fabulous celeb sparkled party
but it was just not conducive
in the hills i i don't know if i would
live in the valley because they say it's
much hotter and the traffic's terrible
like
i would have to live in a compound in
beverly hills oh yeah beverly hills
like i just think like not all la real
estate is like this but they happen to
specify on sunset hollywood hills
and that's what the houses are i would
never live there yeah no i
i don't think that i could live there
either yes of course i would love to
live in beverly hills but right now
they're just showing us homes
in the valley and sunset but that
beverly hills compound the 80 million
dollar divina listing
was the most sickening and i think it
was christine who said this because
she's [ __ ] brilliant she was like
millionaires have views billionaires
have compounds
yeah because that big house the 44
million dollar house and like i need to
know who
i hope one of them has to sell it
because like oh well by the way since
the show has come out there's been all
these things like most of the listings
aren't real most of the scenarios aren't
real
no i don't want to know that that's the
million dollar did emily not buy that
house i don't know
i don't want to know because i like to
live but you have to assume that a lot
of it is not in that reading nook
right now having a coffee i don't think
so no i don't i can't
i refuse i'm believing what i'm seeing
okay okay
anyways i really hope that 44 million
dollar house like is part of the story
line and that one of them sells it
because whoever does is gonna be like
the big man on campus um and then the
second season
there was a lot to unpack so far larsa
pippen obviously
yeah it's a fabulous just moment i
really hope she bought that house
i was talking to her instagram last
night i don't think she did i don't know
the picture that you sent me like it
could have been the house but the tv
wasn't behind the kitchen it was on the
side
maybe she moved it but it was really
funny that that agent was like
her son is like looking for a basketball
court and then they
get to the house and like and michelle's
like and the basketball court
is like oh that's cool yeah i feel like
that's literally how like celebrity
works it's like all this misinformation
by people's people like being swapped
around
um but what was so crazy is when sorry
when rochelle was like showing that
house at first
i was like oh damn this is the perfect
house for that couple that christine
showed that swanky bachelor 10 million
dollar bachelor pad last season
and then i was so glad that she brought
them to this house yeah it's interesting
how it works like with them all working
together
um but season two when christine just
like comes out of her jet with her new
fiance her rich tech fiance and her new
life like
she leveled up to like another planet
and i as a
christine you know supporter was like a
living for it you guys like we have
absolutely no choice but to stand and
and i don't understand i don't want to
understand anyone who like didn't see
that and was like jaw was on the floor
like i officially am team christine ride
or die
i'm getting to a point where i don't
even care if she's gonna do so so far to
me yeah everything she does is like
justifiable justifiable i understand i
think she's
like on point but i'm getting to a point
like you know the money samuel's point
where
i don't even care i i don't care what
she's gonna do like i'm gonna have her
back
um did you see in real time most
recently christine is not only on the
cover of maxim magazine looking like a
[ __ ] fiery snack
she also got married yes and she wore a
black
wedding dress yes and i saw on netflix
when i was looking through the episodes
like i think
the end of season three the finale is
her wedding oh
which is great oh my god amazing i mean
literally the pictures i saw on
instagram
it was not my taste but incredible like
the flowers it was literally like a
multi-million dollar wedding
yeah no i'm so excited i hope we see it
yeah i hope
i'm really i'm just really excited i
feel like all the good stuff like now
we've gotten to know everyone some
people unfortunately like are wasting
our time i love amanza by the way i like
really really respect her and like i
just want things to work out for her so
she can
provide for her family i totally agree
but now like they're
turning like there's two squads is what
i've realized and it's christine
davina and heather no not christine and
davina
christine christine sorry that i get
christine christelle
is so confusing christine davina and
heather because heather has nowhere else
to go and also like
i thought christine like was not about
heather i'm not about heather
versus mary crechelle and amanda and i
just need to swap them in amanda and
heather
i agree and the amanda birth heather
thing like heather was [ __ ]
mean heather was so wrong and when she's
like mind your business and it's like
a man's show like you want people to
mind if i just stop talking about your
public information
in the office you didn't mind me my not
minding my business when i was agreeing
with you
right but now i'm going to say something
that you don't want to hear like she's
so [ __ ] defensive about her
relationship like jason or brett will
just say like
oh how's torik and she's like what'd you
say
she's so crazy she's she's so crazy also
i
can't believe and her and are still
together yeah and i
love that she loves her step kids but
like her comparing what she's doing with
maya maya was like it's not the same no
it's oh maya is amazing and she's
neutral
and i i really really like her but also
at one point she was like
i think when she was talking to jason in
his apartment when she was trying to
like move in oh what was that begging to
move in not okay it's one thing to make
a joke but literally no she said it like
five or six times it was so weird and
she was this is my room
and then she was like talking about her
relationship she's like
it's a lot you know i'm kind of like a
stepmom and she's like i'm mom and i'm
like
how do you think christina feels seeing
that
who like birthed these children you've
been around for three weeks yeah
[ __ ] and you call yourself mom chill
um okay so all in all
i really enjoy the show i'm gonna i
don't want my opinion to change and i
know i
i can't state this enough times like
don't come for us for our opinion we are
who we are and i'm just
when when you wonder how someone can
like christine
versus christelle just remember there
are two types of girls in this world
christine's and christelle's which one
do you want to be yeah
yep yep yep yep um
okay and now our final segment is dear
toasters
our advice segment if you ever want to
write in the email is dear toasters
gmail.com we always keep it anonymous
and we will read
your query on air and then we will do
our best to give you advice
so let's dive right in the first one
jackson claude my best friend's starting
a guy
oh my god sorry my best friend started
dating a guy jake in college who was
always the life of the party
he's hilarious but has always been very
touchy feely with other girls and guys
all of our friends just thought he was a
little different until a few weeks ago
while hanging out with a bunch of
friends jake proceeded to get very drunk
and his true
colors showed he started hitting on my
fiance and asked him to show him his
weenie
of course my fiance said hell no dude
and walked away
he did this to multiple guys at the
party the sad thing is that my friend
thinks that they're gonna
that she and jake are gonna get married
and she's expecting a ring soon how do i
tell her that jake
is definitely gay i don't know if
jake is necessarily gay yeah boys like
do weird things like in locker rooms and
[ __ ]
and show me your weenie okay definitely
sounds a little gay
but i don't know i think that if jake
was really in the closet
he probably wouldn't be publicly asking
to see someone's penis
yeah i think i don't think you need to
tell your friend that her boyfriend is
definitely gay
i think you tell your friend that your
boyfriend asked to see
your boyfriend's weenie and let her
decide if it's something she's
comfortable with
yeah because if someone said that to me
about ben i would um
i would raise an eyebrow yeah no i would
definitely
ask some questions yeah like why did you
want to see the weenie
yeah why did you call it a weenie
because that's even weirder
and well we need to talk yeah like what
would if you had seen the weenie like
were you gonna measure you know put some
mustard on it like what
sword fight i am honestly most the most
concerning thing here is not that jake
wanted to see someone's penis is that
it's a grown man called it a weenie
yeah because that's a hot dog i think
this is just good advice perry but what
you need to do in the situation is just
relay
only the information that you know for
certain right like don't put your
personal spin on it yeah which is what
you saw and what you heard yeah not what
you think
it's weird but sometimes people are just
weird yeah
it's not always something you know yeah
and also like this guy you say it's the
life of the party like maybe parties are
changing
and now you're showing everyone our
wieners honestly like he's the type of
guy would get married and like literally
go to swingers parties like and just
show everyone his weenie yeah but like
i don't know i just feel like when
you're the life of the party like let's
think about jake for a second
there's a lot of people constantly be
the life of the party
and like you can't do the same trick you
did it last party yeah no you're getting
stale it's like that episode of sex in
the city where that pregnant woman
who used to be like the life of the
party and like take her top off
everywhere
she's pregnant now and so she can't do
that but she like really wants to be the
life of the party so she does it anyway
like that's jake
oh my god that oh i thought you were
going to say that also that woman who
falls out the window
yeah that's going to be dude that's like
such a tragic episode um
but yeah think maybe think about where
jake's coming from think about him
yeah like parties are changing and you
gotta switch it up and it's it's really
like a constant burden to like always be
expected to like lift the party up and
maybe you need to do some
self-reflection and be like why does he
feel like he always needs to pump up the
party like
do are we boring right right that's on
you actually and your fiance so you guys
aren't fun
no okay just tell her what you heard and
just like don't put your personal spin
on it just like drop off the information
like an amazon box and then be gone like
a ups man okay
yeah all right dear toasters what
started out as an innocent night of
drinking at a friend's party turned into
an absolute mess
parts of the night are spotty my friend
vicki and i remember the most disturbing
part
so well and i'm not sure if anyone else
involved does vicky myself
and two men whom we've known our entire
lives let's call them
basil and oregano stop okay
um went up to our friend's bedroom and
performed a strip tease
at the time it sounded like a good idea
and in the moment everyone was into it
one thing led to another we all woke up
in the same room we found basil passed
out completely naked on a wicker bench
and oregano i can't deal with the names
and oregano passed out sitting up
wearing nothing but a sailor's cap
and socks at this point vicki and i are
freaking out and finding a way to get
out of the room without waking them up
we eventually escaped and made it home
safely the dreaded day came when we had
to face basil on a regular one person
for the first time since the incident
now these people are all just friends
like yeah when they're boyfriends no
they just like
had a weird like they did weird things
when they were drunk and like now they
have to pay their price okay
the dreaded day came when we had to face
basil and oregano in person
for the first time since the incident
neither of them acted like anything
happened and it seems like they don't
remember
do we pretend we don't remember either
and go on with our friendships as if we
didn't see each other naked
do we address it with the boys to see if
they remember or never mention it again
please help never mention it again
they're obviously not mentioning it
because either they don't want to or
they don't remember it so
you've gotten it out just acknowledge it
and accept it yeah i wouldn't like
go and mention it again the only way
that you could if you wanted to is like
the next time you guys are drunk maybe
not at that level drunk but like
you know if you're drunk again and
they're feeling more comfortable or
maybe things
are going that way again just be like
remember that time
right see if they remember first of all
and and you'll have more bravery like
and so will they yeah so will they but
just to cold column
i mean it's i guess like friends do
weird things when they're drunk with
their friends but
i don't know it's something to be
embarrassed about no but like
you know that feeling of course shame
shame
of course i totally understand and you
know what just ignore it
they're ignoring it so like why are we
even talking about it there's no worse
feeling in the world
than shame that post drunk night shame
and you know what thankfully for
quarantine i really haven't had it yeah
but
it is uh it's enough to make me sober
for the rest of my life
it really is awful feeling it's an awful
feeling
shame but it doesn't feel like she feels
shame like no she just
she feels awkward and like doesn't want
to talk about it which i understand and
it seems like they don't either because
they haven't brought it up
yeah but definitely down in the room
that's what i want to know no one knows
that's
actually maybe if you talk to them maybe
they know yeah it sounds like she
sounds like she said she remembers this
incident specifically the night is
blurry but like she remembers the moment
yeah i don't know i think just if you
guys are drinking together like
with just the four of you again sometime
see feel it out
um but otherwise just be glad that no
one's mentioning it right and just like
don't make it weird
yeah um so those are dear toasters again
if you ever want to write in
the email is dear toasters gmail.com
always kept anonymous don't worry and we
will do our best to give you the best
possible advice
ever um and if that's all she wrote i
think that's all that she wrote we will
continue watching selling sunset
hopefully be done by tomorrow we'll
definitely be done with season two by
tomorrow
um we'll just see about the rest of it
i'm really excited
and it's just been a really fun journey
i look forward to hearing what you guys
think of our comparisons like
tell me that you see that christina
sarah foster not at all and also
our thoughts thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every day on youtube monday through
friday
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we are also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
about my itunes stitcher public radio i
heard video cast box
all the places were now available on
amazon music so wherever you find your
podcast find us the morning toast
and leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much thank you for
listening have an amazing hump day and
don't forget to hump someone you love
we'll see you tomorrow bye